[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais vous faire flipper on va parler
de cybersécurité et on va commencer par
faire un petit sondage dans la salle à
main levée qui utilisent un ordinateur
au quotidien les mal barré
qui dans la salle c'est que pour
protéger son ordinateur où ces données
il faut utiliser des systèmes de
sécurité comme un firewall ou un
antivirus c'est bien vous êtes
conscients des risques vous poser une
autre question qui ce matin en venant à
la conférence en voiture en métro à
vérifier que le firewall de sa voiture
ou du métro était activée
vous êtes vraiment une bande
d'inconscients une voiture c'est un
ordinateur qui roule alors pourquoi être
conscient des risques sur votre
ordinateur
et pas sur votre voiture votre métro je
prendre un autre exemple qui ce matin à
vérifier que le pacemaker de mami avait
son antivirus à jour qui dans la salle a
fait ça il y en a qui voulait toucher
l'héritage pourtant un pacemaker c'est
quoi c'est un ordinateur implanté dans
votre corps qui soutient quand même des
fonctions assez vital pour l'être humain
va y avoir des morts à cause d'un
problème de cybersécurité faut en être
conscient
alors quand je discute cybersécurité
avec mes interlocuteurs la plupart du
temps on parle de vol de données
mes données personnelles on va me piquer
mon numéro de carte bleue
oui c'est possible mais finalement il ya
peut-être des scénarios de risque un peu
plus préoccupant pour nous les citoyens
faut être un peu plus vigilant je vais
vous citer un scénario probable
on est sur l'autoroute tous ensemble
dans la même voiture grosses voitures
on reçoit un sms
le pirate nous dit par sms si vous payez
pas la rançon
je vous débloque pas les freins on fait
quoi
c'est trop tard on paye la rançon
reprenons l'exemple de mamie vous
recevez un sms qui dit si vous payez pas
la rançon
je fais danser le fest-noz hammami toute
la nuit
non mais c'est embêtant
bon moi je pense sincèrement mon point
de vue c'est que tous les citoyens
devraient s'intéresser un petit peu plus
aux problématiques de cyber sécurité
dans leur vie au quotidien dans tous nos
outils numériques au sens très large
la voiture à l'avion moi mon métier
c'est de gérer ces risques au quotidien
donc mon point de vue il est très
certainement influencé par ce que je
fais au quotidien je vous le concède
vous pensez peut-être que je suis parano
qui pensent que je suis parano
ouais vous pensez que je suis parano
non c'est vrai les voitures connectées y
en a pas encore à tous les carrefours
je vous le concède par contre ce qu'il y
à tous les carrefours c'est des feux de
signalisation tricolore
sachez que une équipe de chercheurs en
sécurité a détecté une vulnérabilité
dans un système de gestion de
signalisation dans une ville ils ont
juste trouvé un petit défaut de
conception qui avaient un impact de
sécurité et c'est un pacte de sécurité
c'est qu'ils étaient capables de faire
passer à n'importe quel moment tous les
feux sont au rouge soient ouverts en
même temps un feu rouge
c'est un ordinateur ça peut être
compromis or tout ça c'est un peu lourd
moi c'est mon métier
vous et votre vie
faut quand même qu'on essaye en tant que
citoyen d'avoir son propre point de vue
sans être des experts dans le domaine
c'est la deuxième partie on va essayer
de trouver des solutions
alors je vous propose de tactique pour
gérer un problème de cyber sécurité dans
votre vie quotidienne
1 vous appliquer la règle des 5 c vous
la connaissez
c'est con mais c'est comme ça
on peut faire semblant prendre les
risques de cyber sécurité faire un pas
de côté les laissez-passer éviter de les
prendre il tactique deuxième choix qui
me paraît plus participatif je vais vous
donner deux trucs pour avoir votre
propre avis sur ce problème de la cyber
sécurité de vos outils au quotidien
première postulat penser que tous vos
objets du quotidien sont des ordinateurs
ainsi on l'a bien vu tout à l'heure vous
avez quand même quelques bons réflexes
en cybersécurité vous allez donc pouvoir
transférer vos bons réflexes dans vos
outils du quotidien au sens large
votre chaudière votre porte de garage
votre voiture tous après je vous
demanderai de vous poser à chaque fois
que vous êtes face à une réflexion sur
la cybersécurité de penser ou à la
nature du fournisseur qui vous donne le
service si vous êtes face à un
fournisseur hégémonique qui vous offre
un service ics et que vous êtes le seul
ce fournisseur le seul à pouvoir vous
rendre ce service et qu'il utilise une
technologie propre qui est la seule à
pouvoir vous offrir ce service vous êtes
dans une situation un peu risqué et on
est tous dans une situation un peu
risqué puisque 6e fournisseur ou cette
technologie est attaqué la taxe sera
massive
donc tout le monde sera impacté d'un
coup donc réfléchissez à ce postulat
tout est un ordinateur est ce que le
fournisseur de mes outils numériques est
le seul à pouvoir me fournir ce service
ou est-ce qu'il ya d'autres solutions en
fait je pense qu'il faut amener un petit
peu de diversité biologique dans nos
outils numériques ce qui nous permettra
d'avoir des conséquences localisés non
pas généraliser alors si je prends des
exemples qui me concerne
plus personnellement comment j'applique
ça dans ma vie de tous les jours
bon je vais vous citer deux exemples ma
fille a eu un petit accident est tombée
elle va bien maintenant on a
qui était à l'hôpital à l'hôpital a été
surveillé par des scop les dispositifs
médicaux connecté à un réseau
informatique
bon moi j'ai fait mon analyse de risques
un réseau informatique s'attaque
j'ai besoin de pouvoir prévenir une
infirmière ou un docteur si ma fille il
y avait trop de trucs rouge qui arrivait
sur les scop
j'ai décidé de rester dans la salle avec
elle j'ai fait mon choix à vous de faire
votre choix en conscience des risques
pour vous et vos proches
un autre sujet qui nous concerne tous
c'est la démocratie les votes
je crois que ça nous concerne tous
certains voudraient espère je ne sais
pas voudrait clés qu'on vote sur des
systèmes électroniques
c'est une possibilité
maintenant quand on essaye d'appliquer
la petite méthode que j'espère vous avez
appliqué qu'est-ce qui se passe 1 une
machine qui sert à faire les votes c'est
un ordinateur donc déjà là on reprend
nos réflexes généralement cet ordinateur
va être vendue à toutes les mairies et
va y avoir un seul fournisseur
moi j'ai fait mon analyse de risques
préfère le système où je vais dans une
mairie où je dépose ma petite enveloppe
c'est juste mon choix donc les choix que
vous avez à faire avec cette petite
méthode ça sera les vôtres vous les
ferez en conscience et en fonction de
vos risques à vous ou ce que vous
acceptez pour faire des risques donc en
résumé il est à mon sens important que
tous les citoyens sachent prendre en
compte de manière autonome les aspects
de cyber sécurité dans leur vie au
quotidien
une fois que vous avez analysé et pris
conscience de vos risques en utilisant
le postulat est la question sur
l'hégémonie des fournisseurs
vous êtes amène tout seul sans être un
expert technique de faire vos choix
mais rappelez-vous de seule chose tous
les outils numériques que vous utilisez
le quotidien ce sont des ordinateurs
je vous remercie de votre attention dans
tous les sens du terme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à